today we're going to be speaking with
justin guest who's an associate
professor of policy and government at
george mason university and also author
of several books including the
forthcoming book majority minority out
next tuesday a really great having you
on i appreciate your time
thanks dave it's great to be with you
so um when we kind of study and talk
about reactionary thinking and ideology
which is often fear-based
it's hard not to stumble across fear
being generated
with this idea that people different
than you are going to take over and
become the majority in your area country
region whatever and that's going to be
bad and that'll be dangerous and you
know some sometimes tucker carlson
sometimes says uh dirtier and poorer
will be the outcome of that
so uh this idea of minority majority
groups and the changing demographics has
been used for a very long time to
achieve political goals can you talk a
little bit generally to get us into this
about the different types of reactions
that societies have when we see the
racial or ethnic balances shift
sure it's a great question david you
know it depends on whether we're talking
about this at the individual level or at
the societal level and at the societal
level we know precious little about how
big societies governments respond to
great demographic change and that's
really what motivated this book majority
minority now at the individual level
there is actually extensive research
what happens when we alert people or
simulate great demographic change and
then and the findings are pretty
consistent people are territorial
they're defensive uh they're fearful
they're insecure and most of it is
driven by uncertainty
by the uncertainty of what will life be
like under these uh scenarios
and
uncertainty
generally comes with
the fear that it might not be so good
right i mean uncertainty in in a taken
in a sort of
uh literal way could just mean we don't
know but oftentimes uncertainty is
associated with well that that sounds
like it could be bad
well it takes a special type of human i
think to sort of embrace uncertainty you
know generally you know human reactions
to uncertainty are going to be fearful
uh because of the insecurities
associated with it uh you fear what you
don't know um you know there are some
people who seize the future who sees the
prospects of uncertainty but yes
generally the you know fear is one of
the primary emotions if not just anxiety
or discomfort are there societies that
have been able to kind of embrace
demographic shifts that are significant
without significant conflict
so embrace is a strong word i think
that's actually a standard that i don't
think we even need to necessarily meet
um i think what we really are looking
for are societies that can can foster
and
cultivate a culture of coexistence um
you know and so my work is really
concerned about whether societies pivot
towards conflict or towards coexistence
because there's always going to be some
degree of backlash some degree of
discomfort and i find that to be
universal in all the different societies
that i study that have already undergone
a majority minority transition and by
that i mean where the majority ethnic or
religious group loses its numerical
advantage to one or more minority groups
and in those situations you can always
expect some degree of conflict some
degree of anxiety but the question is
whether societies are resilient and can
redefine who they are in order to evolve
with the changing composition of their
people so can you give us some examples
of where it's gone on the better side
and on the not so good
sure sure so i studied six countries six
societies really carefully uh in this
book uh and uh two societies uh really
pivoted towards suppression of
minorities um the most overt kind of
suppression takes place in the middle
east region and i study bahrain a small
island off the coast of the arabian
peninsula where you effectively have a
sort of second-class system for
immigrants
but also a second-class system for
people of a different religious sect
than that of the ruling uh uh royal
court and party um alternatively you can
look at singapore which is another
society that is characterized by
suppression but in a far more subtle way
singapore is concerned with evolving
into a greater sort of civic identity
but in its policy making and the way it
governs it actually reinforces ethnic
divisions between its people
now if you take a look at some american
examples so hawaii which many people
obviously associate as america's 50th
state um
hawaii was previously an independent
kingdom and when it was an independent
kingdom before it was forcibly annexed
by the united states in 1893 hawaii was
actually a very multi-ethnic and
majority minority monarchy and in that
society hawaii actually embraced many of
these newcomers and actually facilitated
uh intermarriage among them now that's
not to say there wasn't some nationalism
there wasn't some backlash there was
but there was a sort of greater
understanding of what it means to be a
native hawaiian and that it could be
something that was shared and bestowed
upon someone that really took on new
meaning in the 20th century after
americans took over the the archipelago
because the americans put in a very
strong assimilationist regime that
basically treated any person of color
any person who was not white
anglo-american as
uh as someone to be dominated in a sense
and so what you saw was a lot of
intermingling among hawaiians with
people who were previously thought of as
immigrants the japanese the chinese the
filipinos and that intermixing create a
reconception of what it means to be
hawaiian in the future
that's interesting and there you know
it's it's very popular among some in the
united states to say
hawaii is just a mess and they give
different reason reasons why
uh but um
not often cited
is this i mean it's it's interesting you
would think because hawaii tip is a blue
state typically votes for democrats you
would think that the right might have
wanted to seize on multiculturalism is
the reason why hawaii is a mess
economically or whatever it is that
that's often stated but maybe it's not
even necessarily that well-known a story
in the united states i don't know
yeah i don't think of hawaii as a mess
at all i think of it actually as a
paragon in many ways um you know the way
that they have been able to embrace
demographic change over the course of
their history to broaden the
understanding of what it means to be uh
kanaka you know to be a native hawaiian
um is really actually exemplary for how
i think we want to evolve the civic
identity of what it means to be american
um
very generally speaking top level
there's the idea that in the united
states the way the political divisions
are
the left tends to be more accepting of
demographic changes while the right
tends to be more
fearful and critical of demographic
changes can you flesh that out a little
bit more in terms of whether that
general assessment
is always or mostly correct and maybe
some of the exceptions or kind of
strange interplays to this perspective
sure it wasn't always true particularly
when the left was associated with
unionism um which in historically
speaking we're talking 80 to 100 years
ago um was actually relatively closed
and kind of reproduced a lot of the
social uh uh
and cultural inequities in american
history um but certainly in the
contemporary moment that's true um
generally speaking the left not only
embraces uh demographic change it almost
anticipates it um you know with the
election of barack obama many democrats
crowed about
demography being destiny and how this
was the path to electoral victory
forever after um and certainly
republicans have not just um you know i
i think you know fear uh demographic
change but they've actually leaned into
that fear and allowed it to consume much
of its politics until now um in many
ways the republican party is very
nostalgic party right now uh yearning
for for an earlier period in american
history that when they could make
america great again um and so you know
in light of that demographic you know
the relationship with demographics i
think that is generally the case but
it's also been reinforced by our
politics um ever since the democratic
party really moved to the center
economically and embraced kind of
greater neoliberalism the real
differences between the the democratic
party and the republican party in the
united states are principally on
cultural um issues right now right uh i
mean certainly there are economic
differences but the real you know gaps
are on cultural matters and a lot of
that is about how you treat uh minority
groups whether they're uh minorities uh
because of their sexuality because of
their ethnicity because their religion
um whatever it is you know generally
speaking that is where you see the
greatest kind of um
rift
yeah it seems even things like wanting
uh a citizenship question on the census
or the focus on critical race theory to
the extent that any of the people
focusing on it understand what it is the
these things seem to be not so
indirectly related to exactly these same
issues we're talking about
oh i i think you're being modest uh they
are directly related okay politics of
demographic change absolutely um you
know one of the uh greatest dividers um
but also uniters uh in the in in the
course of history uh of great
demographic change and majority minority
transitions is the socialization of
youth you know how we actually
educate our young people uh going
forward and are schools the the sort of
engines of
of uh integration and upward mobility
together are you integrating your
schools and are you learning a common
language and moving forward together or
are you going to have debates over what
we teach in schools uh and many ways you
know textbooks have have actually have a
long history of being debated whether
they recognize the contributions of
minorities over history uh how you treat
um historic inequities and and perhaps
the inconvenient truths of of the
country's history um that's quite common
and then you know with regard to census
questioning that's a matter of power uh
when you are excluding you know people
from a population count you're also
excluding them from power and so these
questions are integral and they're
produced by the fraught politics of
demographic change can you give some
other examples of the the sort of uh
battles that are being had so we've got
the citizenship question critical race
theory you've talked about textbooks and
how history is uh taught there's let's
make english officially the one official
language of the united states what are
some of the other kind of uh uh ways in
which we can see this battle thought
sure you can see it in the battles over
culture
over music and over art and over uh
sports
i think back to khan kaepernick's
effective cancellation from the nfl
when he was taking a knee before the
national anthem in protest of police
brutality and discrimination i think of
the battles over confederate monuments
and the desire to protect them right um
you can also look at the world of
commerce you know do we see racialized
poverty or do we see the the marketplace
as a as a place of interdependency
the politics of affirmative action in in
whether it's
education or employment
all of these are very much related to
demographic change and how we manage it
so there's the question there's sort of
empirical questions about is the
demographic change happening and what
data points do we have as you've
researched in the book about other
places that that it's happened that's
one side of it there's also the reality
that
for a lot of people
this rhetoric really resonates and
some at least of donald trump's rise to
power was you know mexico's not sending
its best
china's treating us very unfairly
etc you know muslim terrorists are
coming up through the u.s mexico border
uh ms-13 is being quote released into
the community all of this different
stuff
it seems very politically effective and
i'm curious your thoughts on
how can it be diffused so that it's not
so politically effective or is there
something visceral about it that just
works
sure there is something visceral but it
can be defeated and you know politicians
and public officials more broadly uh
including even business leaders and
civil society leaders have to become
more adept at calling out fear mongering
for what it does it divides
and if we are going to survive as a
nation if we are in and this is the most
nationalist thing i think i can say uh
is you want to survive as a nation and
if you want to survive as a nation you
have to cultivate some degree of
solidarity and unity and when you have
you know politicians trying to profit in
the short run to win elections uh on
with divisive rhetoric uh that doesn't
have a huge exidentiary basis um we're
all gonna lose and so i think that you
know the opponents of this kind of
fear-mongering have to call those things
out you know people like donald trump
are trying to divide american society
which weakens us uh in the future it
weakens us economically it weakens us
socially and so i do think that that's
the way forward but complementing that
idea is you can't just tear down the
opposite side tactics you also have to
have a strategic vision yourself and
that's where the creativity comes in we
have to actually cultivate an
understanding of who we are as a country
in one in a way that evolves from the
historic understanding of a white
mainstream uh it has to be one that is
not necessarily hit to race or ethnicity
or religion but one that is about a
civic sense of belonging a civic sense
of purpose yeah i mean it's tough i i
guess
we would benefit from having sort of
like a uh some kind of a pr consultant
help with this conversation but you know
when they say
um
immigrants commit more crime and they're
taking our jobs and so on i mean it's
very it's easy in a sense to say
that stuff's not true and here we have
all the studies and native born
americans commit crime at a higher rate
and why wouldn't they they don't have a
fear that they're committing crime in
a different country you know we can do
all that stuff but it just seems like
you're kind of you know pushing a
boulder up a mountain in a sense because
it's just it's always tougher to to
interject facts when the emotions work
so well
sure well look we have to invalidate
these falsehoods you know when they're
being made we can't let them stand
because uh they shouldn't stand you know
they're completely false and
in some cases they're just exaggerations
in other cases they're absolutely false
um but that's a negative strategy you
have to have an affirmative strategy too
right uh and you know whether it's a pr
agency or just some visionary right um
have to work as a country i think as a
people with a million leaders not just
one uh who is thinking clearly and
strategically about what holds us
together as a country what holds us
together as a nation and what's the best
argument is is it basically this country
is built on
people from all over coming here and
contributing what they have to
contribute and we almost all of us are
here for that reason and it's it's it
it's is i mean i don't even know i'm
kind of thinking out loud here about
what is that positive vision sure well
let me give you some fodder and you know
we can keep we can keep the conversation
going uh offline you know and all of you
can continue to think about this in the
shower and that you know tomorrow
morning um there's some there's some
enormous advantages that the united
states has in reconceiving who we are
you know first off we are a country
where everyone has some kind of
immigrant story even native americans
these days are heavily intermarried with
people of immigrant origin and so almost
every single american is touched somehow
by a journey to this country and that is
something that is
remarkably unifying
secondly we have a really high rate of
intermarriage and mixed uh ethnic
ethnicity mixed religion children um
being born right now in fact actually
the rate of mixed race people has grown
by 300 percent that's threefold over
just the last 10 years which is blurring
the boundaries between people that can
otherwise be used to divide us
um and so we also have a very strong
civic idea of what it is to be an
american and so these are all advantages
i think in in crafting that new american
story that other places simply don't
have
that rich history and heritage of
immigration that continues into the
future and so in many ways america is
not one static thing and it's you know
it's it's a fool's errand to try to
create something monolithic it's just
not who we are we're an evolving place
we're an idea we're a country that is
constantly in motion always under
construction and i think that our common
story really comes through in our common
struggle and the idea that everyone
wants to dream yeah the the the reality
that race and ethnicity are also just on
a very practical level increasingly
blurry due to what you're talking about
that that's an interesting uh factor as
well the book is out next week march
22nd the book is majority minority we've
been speaking with the author justin
guest who's also a professor at george
mason university really appreciate your
time today justin thank you anytime
david thank you